he's attacking the white bishop with the
black queen now from the side but
pregnant okay he backs that bishop up
with his pawn
i think he could have moved that bishop
maybe safely but okay we see a check now
on the diagonal and whoa
yeah again the white king just in too
much trouble pregnant no time and he's
on the defensive side it's impossible to
defend when you have 20 seconds left and
a hallucination and it didn't affect
anything and look at that
shaking his head and smiling at the same
time it's a what i call a happy accident
those are very rare in chess i mean
if you make a bad move that's usually uh
very bad news they're more common than
you think yeah yeah
um
this is a skewer the white queen is now
just
has to give itself up for this black
rook yeah like defended by its bishop
and
okay even more brutal magnus is going to
take some pawns first next move the
black bishop's going to retreat with a
deadly check and there we go we have a
result pregnant giving up
oh and pregnant he just logs off